[Musik]
belinda hilfst du mir bei der
gartenarbeit
melinda hilfst du mir bei der
oma tante baby das macht spaß
weil das wetter schlecht war
habe ich mich diesen frühling nicht so
gut um einen garten gekümmert
jetzt haben wir viel arbeit
weil das wetter schlecht war habe ich
mich diesen frühling nicht so gut um
meinen garten gekümmert
jetzt haben wir viel arbeit
kein problem tante baby ich gärtnerei
sehr gern
richtig du bist eine fleißige kleine
gärtnerin belinda
kein problem tante baby ich gehe sehr
gern richtig du bist eine fleißige
kleine gärtnerin belinda
nomen
der garten die gärten die gartenarbeit
die gartenarbeiten der gärtner
die gärtner
die gärtnerin
die gärtnerinnen
werben gärtnern im garten arbeiten
zuerst müssen wir das unkraut und die
toten pflanzen entfernen
ich hätte und du benutzt den rechen
super das beet sieht jetzt schon schön
aus und der grüngut container ist auch
schon fast voll
super das beet sieht jetzt schon schön
aus und der grüngut container ist auch
schon fast voll
um die erde zu glätten brauchen wir die
harke ich hole sie im gartenhaus
harke ich habe sie im garten haus geholt
du kannst gut haken
nomen die pflanze die pflanzen
das unkraut der rechen dir essen die
harke die haken
der grüngut container die grüngut
container die erde
das beet die beta das gartenhaus die
gartenhäuser
werben
jeden dessen haken
ich habe im treibhaus setzlinge gezogen
wir können sie jetzt ins bett pflanzen
jetzt brauchen die kleinen pflänzlein
dringend wasser
ich nehme den wasserschlauch
warte wir nehmen die gießkanne
ich nehme den wasserschlauch warte wir
nehmen die gießkanne
wasser ist besser für die pflanzen
wenn die kleine lea ist füllen wir sie
im wasser fass wieder auf
in die kanne lea ist füllen wir sie im
wasser fass wieder auf
ins wasser habe ich brennesseln getan
diese wilde pflanze wirkt als dünger
nomen das treibhaus die treibhäuser der
setzling die setzlinge
der wasserschlauch die wasserschläuche
die gießkanne die gießkannen
das wasserfass die wasserfest
die brennnessel die brennesseln der
dünger die dünger
werben
pflanzen gießen
jetzt sehen wir kräuter in töpfen an
du kannst die samen leicht mit erde
bedecken
jetzt sehen wir kräuter in töpfen an
du kannst die samen leicht mit erde
bedecken
bewässern können wir sie mit der
sprühflasche
hallo hallo
opa und nizza hallo hallo opa und nizza
ich möchte den rasenmähern und ich helfe
ihm mit meinem kleinen rasenmäher
dann machen wir mal eine pause
nomen der topf die töpfe der samen die
sollen
die sprühflasche die sprühflaschen der
rasen
die rasen
der rasenmäher die rasenmäher
werben ansehen verbessern
geht ein wurm
[Musik]
würmer sind gut sie verbessern die erde
firma zählen zu den nützlingen
ebenso wie bienen
bestäuben die pflanzen und sorgen so
dafür dass es früchte gibt
ebenso wie bienen sie bestäuben die
pflanzen und sorgen so dafür dass es
früchte gibt
und schnecken
nacktschnecken fress und gemüse und
salat
sie sind schädlinge
zum glück hat diese schnecke ein haus
sie frisst lieber tote pflanzen
nacktschnecken fress und gemüse und
salat sie sind schädlinge
zum glück hat diese schnecke ein haus
sie frisst lieber tote pflanzen
gegen die bösen schnecken helfen igel
sie fressen sie sehr gern
deshalb mache ich im herbst immer ein
haus aus laub für die igel
gegen die bösen schnecken helfen igel
sie fressen sie sehr gern
deshalb mache ich im herbst immer ein
haus aus laub für die igel
ein marienkäfer ist auf seinem hut
gelandet
keine angst marienkäfer sind gut sie
fressen die schädlichen blattläuse
ein marienkäfer ist auf deinen hut
gelandet
keine angst marienkäfer sind gut sie
fressen die schädlichen blattläuse
der käfer zählt aber zu den schädlingen
der dickmaulrüssler
ein anderer käfer zählt aber zu den
schädlingen der dickmaulrüssler
wie auch die raupe hat er unsere
pflanzen zum fressen gern
nützlinge der wurm die würmer die biene
die bienen
der igel die igel der marienkäfer die
marienkäfer
schädlinge die schnecke die schnecken
die blattlaus die blattläuse die raupe
die raupen
der dickmaulrüssler die dickmaulrüssler
hallo ich bringe den rasentrimmer zurück
danke onkel willibald danke onkel
willibald
hallo ich bringe den rasentrimmer zurück
ich muss ja noch meine hecken schneiden
[Musik]
ich hole die heckenschere
ich muss ja noch meine hecken schneiden
können wir jetzt endlich die früchte
ernten
ist ja gut du kannst die beeren pflücken
und ich steige auf die leiter und ernte
die äpfel und pfirsiche
ist ja gut du kannst die beeren pflücken
und ich steige auf die leiter und ernte
die äpfel und pfirsiche
so das ist der letzte kürbis jetzt sind
wir fertig
nomen
der rasentrimmer die rasentrimmer
die hecke die hecken die heckenschere
die heckenschere
die leiter die leitern
die beere
die bären
der apfel
die äpfel
der flüssig die physische
der kürbis
die kürbisse
werben
ernten
pflücken
arbeit ist auch du gern im garten
was planst du am liebsten an
schreibe es in die kommentare
[Musik]